[Music]
hello and welcome to a special spectator
event smart money how to use less energy
and save on your bills I'm Kate Andrews
a spectator's economics editor and your
host for the next 45 minutes today's
virtual event is kindly sponsored by
Smart Energy GB
when bills rocketed last year the
fragility of Britain's energy security
was exposed a year on we have a new
department for energy security and a
pledge from the Secretary of State Grand
chaps to have the lowest energy bills in
Europe
how are we going to achieve this
managing demand is going to factor in
too so how can consumers take control of
their energy usage and save money in the
process what does this future look like
and how would that reduce Britain's
Reliance on imported energy well to
answer all of these questions and more
I'm joined by three experts we have
Charles hedgery who is the president of
the British Institute of energy
economics he was formerly a conservative
MP and for two years the minister of
State for climate change responsible for
the smart meter rollout
Sarah Hyman is the director of corporate
Affairs at Smart Energy GB and oversees
the organization's relationship with
industry and government and David
shipworth is a professor of energy and
the built environment at University
College London his research focuses on
demand flexibility in the energy system
so let's get into it but right before I
start with my questions I want to
encourage you to submit yours we've
already had some pre-submitted questions
for today's event but you can ask
questions live there's a text box just
below the video where you can submit
your question that comes straight to the
spectator team and I'll be getting to
those in about 20-25 minutes although
I'm going to start with a few of my own
so Charles I'm going to come to you
first everyone has heard now about the
need to secure Britain's energy Supply
to what extent is this really feasible
especially in the short term
it's absolutely feasible although I
think it may be medium term rather than
short term because that the way many of
the mechanisms which need to be put in
place to guarantee our security take
some years to put in place if we wanted
more gas storage then that's five years
if we want a new interconnector that's
three five years so that some of the big
big projects and new new plant is going
to take some considerable time
to get in place
get on getting a lot of feedback on here
I'm sort of hearing myself speaking
which is uh not ideal I said that can be
cut out
the but I think when it comes to the
theme of today's discussion the smart
meter rollout is absolutely fundamental
to changing consumer behavior and giving
consumers New Opportunities if we want
people in their homes and their
businesses to be part of the solution
here where they can decide when they're
going to generate electricity when
they're going to store it when they're
going to use it when they're going to
sell it back to the grid then that is
only possible if we've got smart meters
installed in our homes and our
businesses so this is the fundamental
building block of creating a much more
flexible and a much more exciting system
it moves consumers from being the
passive recipient of what their energy
companies throw at them to being the
people who decide how they're going to
run their homes so it's a really
exciting change but it also means we're
going to have a much more secure system
we're going to have a huge amount more
flexibility and we're going to be in
it's going to help in decarbonization
it's win-win-win and it ticks the big
box for affordability as well Sarah how
does household energy consumption affect
National energy security
so as Charles variety said and I
couldn't have I couldn't have introduced
it better myself
um when we're thinking about our energy
security it's about balancing Supply
with demand or in the future Demand with
Supply and that's where flexibility of
the system comes into it we recently
published a report with Cornwall Insight
which looked at the the way in which uh
consumers all consumers in their homes
can impact energy Security in a short
medium and long term in the short term
it's about reducing energy where they
can or in fact using it more smartly if
you like rather than using less because
I think the way in which you can change
energy use is deeply personal to each
person and what their household looks
like and they can do that really well
with a smart meter because of the
information that that gives you that
empowers them to make those choices and
then thinking about the medium in the
long term as we see more time of use
tariffs come onto the market which is a
tariff that allows you to be potentially
paid for using less energy or in fact in
some cases using more at different times
of the day
then you'll see even greater
contribution from uh from Individual
households to our energy security you
know I think it's important that we
remember that households in the UK use
about a third of all gas and a third of
all electricity that the UK consumes in
a year and so you know our cumulative
impact on energy Security on the demand
side is significant
um and Charles just to um set the
framework here a little bit more how
secure is Britain's energy Supply right
now I mean last year you had the
government warning about blackouts
thankfully that was largely avoided
um and of course last year was a very
unique year when it came to energy
concerns
um but have we made progress over this
past year I mean where are we right now
when it comes to our own security
I think we've come through this winter
in a way that nobody really would have
anticipated being possible just a few
months ago and now to some extent we
were helped by the weather conditions
part of the winter was milder it meant
the gas storage remained at much higher
levels and people would have anticipated
it means we come out of the winter with
a lot of gas in storage which is very
unusual and that is really good for next
winter because already people have been
starting to get anxious about that but I
think what we've also seen is how we can
then start to change the system and
exactly as Sarah was saying people have
been given the opportunity to say look I
will cut my use during a a period of a
few hours because that's what we're
talking about we're not talking about
days of challenge we're talking about a
few hours on a few days and we can shave
the demand consumers can do that
businesses can do that an Elon Musk was
saying this week he said look you know
if we actually go down this route of
more energy storage more better managed
systems then rather than energy and
electricity use doubling or 12 doubling
over the next 30 years we could actually
find that we can reduce it overall so
this this is a key part of delivering
our energy security I think what the
government is doing and its focus on
addressing these issues is really
important some of those measures are
relatively quick others will take more
time but I think we've had a big wake-up
call February of last year we recognized
we had allowed Europe to become far too
over-reliant on a single source of
supply and we've now got to take energy
security every bit as seriously as we
take affordability and decarbonization
David how far do you think smart meters
will actually help to improve energy
security and is managing the demand side
really more effective than managing the
supply side
it's not a matter of either or it's
always going to be a matter of basically
using the demand increasingly to align
with our supply side so this is both the
sort of opportunity and challenge of
having more and more intermittent
Renewables on our system is that we want
to try and get demand to a certain
extent to match the availability of
supply and that's where the demand side
becomes really deeply entwined with the
supply side to make a system which
balances out over the course of the day
the week and the year
so we're really trying to kind of focus
on how we get that balancing right and
that's where smart meters are an
absolutely integral solution so I also
do quite a bit of work under the
auspices of the International Energy
agency and every other country in the
world is recognizing and rolling out
Smart Meters as a kind of enabling
technology they're a bit like the
equivalent of our kind of smartphones
for the Energy System we really need to
be able to understand when people are
using energy we need to create value for
them to shift that load out of the peak
times because especially for homes homes
create the peaks in the mornings in the
evenings and that's the thing that we
need to kind of shift around so yeah
essential piece of technology and they
really can create value for householders
when you combine them with other bits of
technology that use energy in the home
of course our some consumers
understandably get concerned when we
start talking about changes to the
demand on energy especially already in a
cost of living crisis where people are
scaling back any talk of not using
energy over certain periods of time
might make people a bit nervous do you
think there is a way we can improve
Britain's energy security without
talking about demand flexibility or is
this going to be a crucial Factor
we know that flexibility in the system
is going to be a huge part of energy
security I think the government says
that
um it will save about 10 billion pounds
if you have flexibility not just
consumer flexibility but sort of broader
flexibility assets on the system but
what I would say is you know it's an
understandable question
that people will have particularly in a
cost of living crisis how do I how do I
try and contribute to this how can I try
and save money in a way that's not going
to impact my my life negatively and
that's why I said earlier that actually
the way in which you can get engaged in
this conversation is incredibly personal
to you your family and your household
and an awful lot of the tips the changes
in the short term so you know ways in
which you can you can sort of make
changes now in the home are about using
energy in a smarter more cost effective
way in cutting waste rather than cutting
your necessary energy usage so for
example one of the tips that we've been
working with the energy saving trust to
promote is shower time you know if you
normally have an eight minute shower and
you cut it down to four minutes you can
be saving I think it's in the in the
quantity of about 95 pounds a year for
example and one of the things that I've
done in my home when I moved in my
previous owners for whatever reason had
put an awful lot of spotlights in and
they're all halogen and the moment I got
my smart meter I could see that it went
into the red when I turned turned those
lights on so immediately I went and got
some LED light bulbs for all of those
spotlights and that saved I think they
you know in the quantity of about 100
pounds a year as well and so these
changes that you can make to reduce
waste that don't affect the quality of
your life and actually some of the other
changes you could be making and the
things that we've been talking about
this winter will improve people's lives
in the comfort of their homes so you
know old chimneys that are incredibly
drafty you can you can put these
balloons in there to stop the draft
coming down and that'll help you feel
much more comfortable so it's about not
it's it's how we frame the conversation
it's not about using less it's about
using the energy that we need to use in
a smart way that suits you and your
lifestyle and in the longer term when it
comes to some of these more flexibility
conversations you know it will be there
will be a time I think government says
by mid-2035 when flexibility in the home
will be incredibly integrated people
have hopefully the technology to allow
them to do it in a way that doesn't
impact on their lifestyle so you know
boilers that are incredibly water tanks
are incredible Energy Efficiency you can
store water for longer and heat it out
side of peak times Etc so we're only on
the start of this journey
um but there's so much more to do and
yes it's really important that we make
sure we're having a conversation about
what's comfortable and what smart energy
usage not using less
of course Charles if you look at the
story of carbon emissions in the UK it
is not the case that
um you have to choose necessarily
between Rising living standards and
improving Environmental Quality carbon
emissions have collapsed since their
height in the 1970s and I'm looking at
the per capita figures here back down to
the Victorian era so it isn't
necessarily going to be the case that
consumers are going to have to choose
between higher living standards and
making choices around say technology
like smart meters but that that case
really does have to be made and
explained to people
oh I think so but I think we can also
say look we've done it look at what
we've achieved and I think if you go
back over the last 30 years the economy
has grown by 70 plus percent and we've
cut emissions by 40 plus percent so it's
exactly the point which you're making
there but I think one of the issues
which we haven't addressed sufficiently
so seriously and over over the past has
been Energy Efficiency and that picks up
on what some of Sorrow was saying we're
the most effective way of helping the
energy crisis is by making sure our
homes and our businesses are more energy
efficient now the government is putting
more money into this but actually I
think we do really need to have a step
change in the way in which we're going
about this because otherwise that the
measures which people can take in their
homes will be offset by the fact they're
simply going to be too cold and so that
we need first of all to have this much
more rigorous approach to ensuring all
homes are energy efficient
usage and exactly how they have strain
is on the grid when it's at its peak
well this is a really important point I
think because we're seeing as I was
saying that households introduce the
kind of peak loads in the morning and
the evening a lot of our other loads are
a lot flatter and one of the challenges
we're going to face as we progressively
decarbonize and just picking up on
Charles point the the cheapest way now
to generate energy is through solar and
wind so we're on a declining cost curves
really almost every country is heading
down this road of decarbonizing so what
we need to do is to make that possible
so we can get the benefits of that both
in terms of securing our own energy
Supply but also in terms of having
cheaper energy
but to do that we really are going to
come up against a constraint of how much
power particularly electricity we can
pump through our networks and they take
a while to upgrade so in order to make
that work we need to use our networks as
efficiently as possible and that really
means trying to flatten out when we use
energy so from that side of it when we
think about things like heat pumps and
electric vehicles which are really
efficient Technologies they're much more
efficient ways of heating homes and
moving people around than the
conventional fossil fuel Technologies
but we need to be able to shift those
loads so that you're recharging your
electric vehicle overnight and your heat
pump is you know coming on earlier in
the morning and then maybe not running
at kind of a peak morning or evening
times if we can do that we really help
shift our capacity to use our Renewables
that we've got which are the best way to
achieve energy security and households
are Central to that kind of flattening
out of the load and we need smart
metering to help us understand that and
to shift those loads around
and in terms of understanding Sarah can
you just give us a short explanation on
how demand flexibility service would
work or does work sure so there's two
the two different sort of um options if
you like at the moment so one is the win
to demand service that was run by
National Grid ESO and so that was a
service where they worked with energy
suppliers and other third-party and
contractors who essentially then uh got
their consumers their customers to sign
up to a plan which meant that
after having a a baseline taken from
their energy usage using their smart
meter so the energy Supply basically
knows how much that person normally uses
between four and six on a weekday for
example they are then paid money back
when the winter demand service is ticked
on by National Grid ESO it says we're
you know we're getting a bit tight in
the system between four and six tomorrow
and can you ask your your customers to
turn down they will then get a message
an email a text message however their
supplier was running it to say you know
between those hours if you can turn down
and if there they can demonstrate that
they've turned down and it's the smart
meter recording or half hourly data
usage that is the thing that allows them
to see that you've done that
then you can get money back the other
one is a time of use tariff now there
are some time of use tariffs in the
Market at the moment fewer than there
were because of the energy crisis but
they can work in different ways so some
of them are agile tariffs so one of the
suppliers currently has an agile tariff
in the market and that essentially means
that a day ahead that customer will be
told and it's going to be cheaper or
more expensive during these periods so
turn up or turn down um accordingly and
then the other ones are sort of static
time of use tariffs which is mostly what
one of the EV ones will look like which
essentially says if you can charge your
vehicle overnight
when electricity is cheaper because
there's more abundancy of wind Etc and
there's fewer people using it then it'll
be cheaper for you to do that it becomes
much more cost effective viewers Navy
owner to charge and it means we all
benefit because the system becomes less
peaky so so they're the two ways that
you can do it at the moment but it's
only the start of the process so we're
going to see some big system changes
coming in from 2025 called half hourly
settlement I won't go into the detail of
what that actually means but what it
means for the consumer is all of our
energy suppliers are going to be
incentivized to offer us more of these
products and what they look like we
don't yet know because it'll be a
commercial offer and it'll be down to
individual suppliers to to to see what
works for them and works for their
customers and I think this winter period
and the winter demand service would have
really informed all of us in terms of
the appetite of consumers to get
involved and the early signs are there's
absolutely appetite there
I just want to remind our viewers that
you can submit a question live there's a
text box just below the video and if you
send your question over to The Spectator
team that will be funneled directly to
me and and I want to get to those
questions soon but before we do I I want
to move into an area that I think puts
quite a few consumers off the idea of
smart meters and that is privacy concern
um Sarah people were told that their
energy use data wouldn't be used that it
would be kept private but the government
did take it and use it to design the
energy price guarantee roll out last
year and now they're saying sorry that
they're going to hold it for seven years
for quite vague additional purposes how
do you answer concerns about privacy
in terms of the EPG and and what
information was taken obviously that's
probably you know that's a conversation
to have with desnet what I can do is
reassure everyone who's listening to
this that your smart meter does not
record or hold any personal information
about you so it doesn't know your name
it doesn't know and you know your bank
details anything like that what it does
have is how much energy you've used in
half hourly periods if that's what
you've opted in for and that's only
shared with you and your supplier unless
you've given consent for that process
and so I think the EPG may have been one
of those processes in which they've
they've done that but it is your
information and there's nothing personal
on the media at all and the other sort
of thing to remember as well is that
smart meters aren't using the internet
so it's it's its own separate service
that was designed with the cyber
security people that um GTA gchq to make
sure that it is incredibly robust
um which means make sure that from a
hacking perspective that's not an issue
either so it's well away from the
Internet it's private it's it's doing
its own thing and in fact the people who
run the network can't even see your
energy usage data it's you and it's your
supplier unless you've given you give
you know explicit consent otherwise the
other thing I would just add was whilst
I'm on this point is that this bit about
giving consent for your energy usage in
the future in order to take part in some
of these fantastic things where you
could get paid to be turning off at
different times Etc or to get more
granular information so that you can
understand what you might be able to do
more in the home to say there's more
money
that's the sort of time when you might
give permission to a third party via an
app or whatever in order to do that but
you would be making that choice and it
would be voluntary for you to enter into
that okay can I add to that as well
because one of the changes I made when
we came into government back in 2010 was
to move this much more towards an opt-in
system because up until that point the
energy companies had the right to break
into people's home to install a smart
meter they haven't used the power but
the power was there and I thought that
that would be the most effective way of
turning people off this and they needed
to be able to opt in I also thought that
the case being made for Smart Meters
shouldn't be done by government
shouldn't be done by industry but really
it should be done by communities and
neighborhoods and where people were
saying look this is how much I'm saving
this is the Improvement it's made in my
life and therefore to make it reassuring
to the consumer that this was not
something which government was imposing
it was something they could opt into
when they chose to do so but also if
they want to get the benefits you can to
get those benefits if the technology is
there and that means having a smart
meter and so it was trying to get the
right balance between moving forward the
rollout but at the same time reassuring
people about privacy about the pace of
the rollout and whether they needed to
have one at all well let me ask you
Charles when the news that this data had
been used for to design the energy price
guarantee came out labor Shadow energy
Minister Alan Whitehead called it an
outrageous piece of private data
plundering would you agree with those
comments no I wouldn't and I think the
urgency of trying to get something in
place that helped consumers was so
enormous that's what we were all focused
on last year how do we actually help
consumers come through this crisis and
the government could only frame that
correctly if it understood more about
how people were using power when they
were using it and that how they could
actually be persuaded to change those
patterns I think that was an inevitable
part of it but the point which Sarah
makes is critical this did not give the
government or the industry any
information about what people were using
that power for and so we saw a tabloid
headline some years ago saying now the
government wants to put a spy in your
fridge suggesting that they will be
monitoring what people had in their
fridge through their smart meters and so
there's a there are scare stories out
there but the government needed to move
quickly to help everybody last year it
couldn't do that without valid
information that information was there
and in so many walks of life the
government in terms in times of extreme
circumstances does have the power to
call on information from different
sources but it didn't compromise
people's privacy as as I was saying
David I love your thoughts on this as
well I suppose for a lot of people who
might be on the fence thinking to
themselves well you know what will be
the next thing that is described as an
extreme circumstance what will be the
next reason given for potentially using
this data and they'll hear about stories
like how data was used for the energy
price guarantee and they'll think to
themselves on the balance I'm not
totally comfortable with this
yeah it's interesting I think just to
step back slightly so the UK
did something very unusual in terms of
smart metering roll out in that it
insisted that the data stay on the meter
in the home and only be released with
the consent of the homeowner and that I
think was really clever in terms of
making sure people stayed in control of
their own data now most other countries
haven't done that and most other
countries do centralize their data so
that's putting that in context I think
it was a good design decision against
the wishes of Industry
um I think it's really important to
understand how little
privately disclosing information you can
get from the smart meter data and as a
researcher we have tried to analyze the
kind of data you get from a smart meter
and work out things about what's
happening in the home and it's
impossible you know we can throw all the
clever algorithms that we can at this
data and because it's you know a half
hourly reading there's very little you
can work out so you know even if we're
trying with all the resources of a
university to do it we can't kind of
hack into this data and understand
things so you there's not a great loss
of privacy as both Sarah and Charles
were saying there I think trust however
is a really important element and I
think just looping back on this I think
the two things we really need are value
propositions to end consumers from
industry and for industry and government
to earn and maintain the trust of
consumers so that they will allow
basically some level of automation of
this they can opt in and say yes you can
pay me
um some money if I allow you to charge
my electric vehicle overnight and unless
we have that kind of trust and value
it's going to be hard to convince
customers so you know I when I look at
this and I think about my own personal
situation I don't see a a kind of threat
in terms of loss of data privacy and
security
um but I think it is a matter of
constantly trying to engage and prove
the trust that we have both with
government and with industry
we've got some great questions coming in
which I'm going to turn to now just a
reminder to our viewers you can submit a
question in the text box just below the
video they come straight to the
spectator team and they're popping up in
front of me now
um so we've got a really good question
here looking at smart meters in the
round and I feel like this is a very
important point about other technology
and how it can impact Smart Meters
someone writes in and says there are
many villages around where I live that
do not have phone signal meaning they
aren't able to stall Smart Meters
despite residents wanting to and trying
to and this person says I failed to see
how smart meters can be that Silver
Bullet what do the panel think so sorry
let's start with you I mean other
technology is going to impact how people
can use their smart meter sure the first
thing to say is that smart meters don't
run off the phone network so that's
that's that isn't impacted and if
there's no phone network your smart
router isn't impacted by that there may
be some areas of the country where we're
still upgrading to make sure that all
smart meters can get onto the system but
get in touch with your energy supplier
and get on the waiting list and you know
the the programs sort of closing in 2025
and there is some time to go and your
energy Supply will get you on that list
and and get a smart meter out to you and
particularly as the energy the
technology continues to develop we were
coming we're overcoming some of the
barriers that we had early in the in the
program in terms of thick walls for
example and sometimes it's signal not
getting through we're getting some new
technology being rolled out this year
called Old Han which will overcome some
of these problems so speak to your
supplier get on the list but it has
nothing to do with paying signal
David is there an inequality when it
comes to smart meter rollout I mean is
it just going to be the case that some
homes are are better fit for this and
that some areas are better fit for this
or is this really truly accessible to
every home
well it will be accessible to every home
but the way that we've rolled out smart
meters is to make sure we learn the
lessons from those homes which we can
start more easily installing smart
meters and so the rollout has kind of
gone through processes of looking at
those homes where they can be relatively
easily installed and then moving on to
some of the ones that are more
challenging and there have been some
challenges in high-rise blocks of flats
for instance but there's been you know a
lot of work on the technology to make
sure those all work so we will get
across to virtually all homes there
might be some you know some homes
remaining that it takes a while to get
through to the to the end of them but
yeah I mean the other thing to say is
that
we need to look at this from a kind of
national picture and you know once we've
got about 50 to 60 of homes I think
currently with smart metering
um that enables a lot of benefits to
come in in terms of GP National energy
security and we need to keep moving
those through the remainder of homes but
yeah I'd throw it back to Sarah in case
she has any you know thoughts about
high-rise or rubber other difficult to
install sectors well good news if your
hand technology that I mentioned is one
of the things that I hope you will be
getting towards the end of this year and
they're in there they're in Trials at
the moment and that should help with an
awful lot of those
Charles there was an article from the
guardian in June 2022 in which smart
meter users were writing in saying that
they had to still have their smart meter
read manually because the signal was
simply not working I mean it does not
sound like the tech is completely there
around Smart Meters yet to make this as
seamless as possible
so this is one of the big infrastructure
investment programs of of the last 20 30
years so this is an enormous program
with huge complexities to it and that
inevitably some parts of the network
will be easier to reach than others but
as Sarah has been and David to be making
extremely clear a huge amount of work
has been going into the technology into
Innovation to ensure that those issues
are addressed
um you're right that there are some
areas which don't get the full service
now but as the rollout continues they
will get it in due course
um we have another question for the
panel about a nationwide micro renewable
energy program that would look at
installing solar panels Smart Meters
mini wind turbines Etc basically asking
should all of these new technologies be
focused on that smaller level and and
really targeting individual Villages and
communities to really convince them and
and and and to also have the proper
balance of different Technologies so
that the communities can really get the
most bang for their Buck Charles let's
start with you well I certainly want to
see that I wanted to see Much Greater
Community ownership of some of those
renewable assets I think that one of the
historic mistakes in the UK has been
that the the main benefits have gone to
the landowners and to the developers and
the owners rather than to the
communities and I'd like to have seen
that change because I think that would
have increased public acceptability but
we will still need large-scale
generation as well if we want to move
the whole of the rail network onto
electricity if we want to sure that we
can roll out electricity for heat pumps
if we want to do it for electric
vehicles and diesel trucks and things
like that at the moment to move them
over then we're going to need more
electricity and then therefore doing
that at a large scale it makes sense and
if you look at where the UK has an
extraordinary advantage in terms of our
offshore wind capacity then that's an
area which we have invested strongly in
and we need to continue doing so as the
government plans it's a mixture so it's
a mixture of large-scale investment a
lot of grid infrastructure to support
that and then more more localized
investment and domestic investment and
the Energy Efficiency it's a mixture of
all of those
Sarah what's your experience speaking to
Industry and consumers are are people
swayed by the decision to take up a
smart meter because of some national
program or does it happen that their
neighbor has one or some local company
is offering something and that's why
they become interested
if different things appeal to different
people and so one of the things we do at
Smart Energy GB is is the national
engagement program if you like and we
see that for some consumers thinking
about the benefits to the the sort of
environment particularly thinking about
conserving our way of life for children
grandchildren and making sure they're
doing their bit of the environment is
incredibly powerful for them whereas for
others it will be about the here and the
now and trying to find ways in which
they can save money I I did want to talk
a little bit about the community energy
bit that we touched on then there are so
many lovely opportunities here with
smart meters to facilitate Community
energy I'm aware of some trials that
have happened in the last couple of
years there's a really nice one in mid
Wales where essentially it looks at how
you can take a village
um or a town where they've got local
Renewables and by having a smart meter
in their house they can turn up or turn
down their usage when that local
renewable is available so they can make
sure that you know we're not losing
usage through going through longing
cables they can use the wind that's
that's there right next to them and make
sure they're getting Financial benefits
as a result and I think the more that
people have Smart Meters in homes and
the more that these sorts of programs
and trials can can come to scale then
the more opportunity for consumers and
and I think it's you know it's fantastic
that we can help local energy be used
and made
um in local towns
David what's what's your experience of
of how you actually reach out to
Consumers governments love a national
program but sometimes the stuff is
better delivered locally
yeah it's I think this is one of the
most interesting areas and I mean
Charles is Right basically it's going to
be a mixture of large-scale offshore
wind farms Etc but very recently there
have been studies that shown that by
installing PV for example on rooftops
and using that energy locally that
actually allows us to use more of our
offshore wind because what it does is it
takes the pressure off the network we
have phrases like local for local so if
you can generate energy on your rooftop
and use it locally then you're not
having to drag Energy across the network
great distances and that means the
Network's got more capacity to bring in
that power from offshore wind or
large-scale solar the other thing we've
done we've worked with a lovely company
called repowering London we worked they
they put a PV array on the rooftop of
the social housing block and a battery
in the basement and then with those two
technologies they were able to cut the
um basically the energy bills of the
people in those blocks by about 20
percent
and so what you're doing is you're using
that power where it's needed when it's
available locally and by having a
battery you can start to take the
pressure Off the Grid at peak times so
you can you know put energy in that
battery when there isn't Network
constraints take it out when there is
and again that really cuts down the cost
of having to upgrade all of our networks
you know otherwise kind of having to you
know upgrade infrastructure and dig up
roads and put in secondary power
substations so local for local is great
and it helps also with the large-scale
offshore stuff
um we've had a question in that I think
will sum up what a lot of consumers
watching the show today will be thinking
um which is um how much money can a
smart meter save me now Sarah of course
you would have to know a lot of details
about the person's situation to give any
kind of specific figure to that but
let's speak more broadly here you know
what kind of savings are we talking
about for consumers sure as I said
earlier you know the way in which you
respond to having your smart meter in
the home and and how you use that
information is very personal to each
individual household and family and so
you know it's hard for me to say what
that could look like I know the
government when they looked at this in
2019 said that they thought it was about
three percent you could save on gas
um two percent on on electricity or it
might have been the other way around but
um we do know from research that we've
done that you could be looking up to 20
savings if you really go for it if you
like so if there are things that you've
been doing in your home that are wasting
a lot of energy and your smart meters
help you diagnose those I know that I
was talking to one smart meter in store
like who said that he was able to help a
woman save 60 pounds a month off her
bills because when she had that smart
meter installed they were able to see
that her interest to usage was
dramatically more than the profile of
the homes near where she lived and so
there was something going on and it soon
transpired her and the uh the Smart
Energy engineer were able to find out
that what she had in her shed which she
termed her barbecue meat fridge freezer
that she had out in her shared head was
so old one of those big old chest
freezers that the Rubber seal had gone
and essentially the lid therefore was
open and she was using all this energy
to refrigerate her entire shed or
however you know sort of the physics of
all of that are working but in essence
it was costing you a huge amount of
money and so as a result of going
through this process and the Diagnostics
she was able to stop using her barbecue
barbecue freezer and and get a new one
um and I think it's it's not just those
immediate savings that people can make
so seeing that me seeing with my uh
lights for example that I need to get
LEDs in instead of halogen it's also
about the feedback you get so as you
make those changes you can see that your
bill is going down and that we know from
our research first people are on to do
more things and actually one of the
things that um has come out of our
insights in terms of that behavior
change is that people who have had a
smart meter are far more likely to be
researching how they can buy more Energy
Efficiency products so you know making
sure that the next time they get a white
good or a freezer that they are looking
for the most energy efficient version of
those so it's all about sort of putting
you giving you the information that you
need
um to make those smart choices and I'm
sure there'll be lots of people watching
there saying you know what and I know
how to use my energy in the most
effective way I've always done it that
way and I may remember the three-day
week of the 70s when when you know homes
were a lot more alive to the impact that
they were having on the electricity grid
and the power right
but we know there are an awful lot of
people that that don't have that
information and this winter has you know
for for good or real helps people
understand that a little bit more and
start to make those changes you know our
research shows that those people who
have got a smart meter have felt more in
control this winter
um and it's given them the information
that they felt they needed to make those
make those changes so as I say in terms
of what those cost changes look like and
it is different for you but if you are
looking for estimates and energy saving
trust which is a fantastic charity and
they've done an awful lot of research to
start quantifying what some of those
changes are and certainly I mentioned
earlier for example if you go from an
eight minute shower uh to a four minute
shower you're talking about 95 pounds a
year and if you avoid using your tumble
dryer really important as you start
getting to slightly drier times and you
could be looking at 70 pounds a year so
you can see how these changes can we
start adding up and they're things that
don't necessarily you know detract from
your lifestyle if you like their smart
ways in which you can assure you're not
wasting energy
Charles and that's so interesting what
Sarah just said about uh households this
winter felt more in control of their
situation if they had a smart meter I
mean I personally come from The View
that um you know data is King but we've
had somebody write in saying and perhaps
slightly jokingly you know I'm not sure
I want my elderly relatives to have
access to this data I think the
implication there and this is a worry
sometimes is that while some people
respond so well to having the data at
their fingertips it could change the
behavior of some other people who
perhaps you know it's more dangerous if
they do change their behavior for
example turning the heating down or off
at certain times when elderly folk
actually really need that more
well I think that's a really valid and
important Point actually I think that
what it for this to be successful as a
program then it's got to be working for
all households and the people who are
new to this and who are uncertain about
it need to have access to Charities like
uh citizens advice or national energy
action who can help to guide people as
to what's going to be right for them
because at the end of the day we don't
want people to be putting themselves
into a situation which is against their
own well-being because they're trying to
save money now we know already those
choices are being made we know it's
winter with people who didn't have the
ability to flex their their their use uh
without making time at times choices
between do I eat my home or do I buy
food to put on the table and so this
comes at the heart of the fuel poverty
issue and this is less about technology
and smart meters than about poverty and
so we need to do more to address those
issues to ensure that people who are
invulnerable situations vulnerable
households have the support which they
need but the big big change which is
happening is that through this
technology through the smart meters
people are going to be much more in
control
up until now we've all been passive
recipients we haven't had any say about
it we may have had a night rate and a
day rate but that was as far as it went
we can now receive signals we can be
told look this is going to be a really
cheap time of day to put on your tumble
dryer or we can make choices to to
continue to use it but to know that
we're going to pay more this is the
first time consumers have been given
that information to make choices and
that's going to be something which I
think is really exciting and empowering
David we've had a question about
requirements for new builds and
basically questioning why in planning
policy there aren't more requirements to
bring in all of these types of renewable
energy and Technology to help us make
um cost efficient and environmentally
friendly decisions
um does this really come down to some of
the discussions we've been having
previous about you know the consumer
Choice element in this building up trust
and not pushing something on someone if
they don't want it
it it's an interesting question around
the regulatory side on this and how we
can use building regulations in
particular to encourage uptake on us but
just just very briefly on the previous
point we actually did a trial in fuel
poor and vulnerable homes in the tower
hamlets region in London which was
funded by off-chem and that was trialing
smart meters and because of gen we're
concerned about people turning down
their thermostats we installed
temperature sensors in all the homes and
we were unable to see any pattern of
people turning down their thermostats in
response to having the smart meter data
and I think it's because they can start
to understand how to use their energy
better so it's this empowering element
with respect to the building regulations
there are a lot of regulations
particularly in Europe
um and I think there are regulatory
changes coming in through our standard
assessment procedure models that are
looking at the benefits that come in
from different Technologies particularly
those around heat pumps so if you
introduce a heat pump into your home you
have a real benefit and so that is now
the direction the regulations are going
for new build Technologies interestingly
in Germany they've just introduced a
piece of legislation that requires that
any heating system that is replaced
after the end of this year has to be a
low carbon one and that's because
they've been so exposed to the price
fluctuations of the the kind of Russian
they're dependence on Russian gas so I
think that's the direction that
regulations are heading we're using that
to really encourage uptake of heat pumps
not so much with PVS because I think
that depends on a wide range of other
factors and the suitability of roof
space but certainly on the heat pumps
we're heading in that direction
um we are just at time so I wanted to
give each of our panelists just one
minute to wrap up their thoughts and
please one minute because I don't want
to go too over so
um Sarah I'll start with you
thank you I think I'll summarize it to
say you know we are all able to help the
energy security of GB
um and we can do that by changing the
way that we use energy and when we use
energy and getting a smart meter isn't
going to be the complete answer to it
but it is one of the tools in our Armory
to help us do that and so if you want to
get a smart meter if you don't already
have one get in touch with your supply
thank you David
yeah I would say that smart meters are
is going to be Central enabling
technology so the way we're going is
towards greater electrification of heat
and transport those are going to be the
most cost effective ways to operate
prices are going to keep coming down
we've seen the US and Europe put half a
trillion dollars just recently into
driving down the costs of these
Technologies without a smart meter you
won't be able to take advantage of those
cost reductions so I think it's really
important that people have a smart meter
in place so they can progressively take
advantage of that
thank you and Charles and to reinforce
what's just been said uh we're seeing a
huge transfer of power now from energy
companies to homes to communities uh
that this is a real chance for them to
be in control the extent to which they
choose to be in control and to use that
is entirely up to them but the access
portal comes from having a smart meter
the smart meter rollout program has been
slower than many of us would have wished
but we're well underway 50 plus of
British homes are now installed with
smart meters and so this is something
which is going to continue and I think
as it goes further people will see more
and more benefits
well thank you so much to our viewers at
the office and at home for tuning in
thank you for your excellent questions
the big thank you to Sarah David and
Charles for your wonderful contributions
thank you so much for joining The
Spectator special event we hope to see
you again soon
foreign